bonsoir lui but au parc des princes il y
avait bien longtemps que les amoureux du
ballon rond on avait vu un tel spectacle
un des plus beau match de l'année entre
paris saint germain et les canaris de
nantes il s'agissait du match retour des
16e de finale de la coupe de france au
parc des princes didier roustan lorsque
l'on compte de but de retard devant une
équipe comme nantes la tactique est
simple il faut attaquer prendre un
maximum de risques et puis si possible
marquer un but dans le premier quart
d'heure on joue depuis seulement dix
minutes de jeu
maintenez sur la gauche pour toko
bas-fonds demain ne peut que repousser
rocheteau et toko qui est toujours là 1
à 0 pour paris saint germain il reste 80
minutes de jeu disons qu'à cet instant
de la partie tout est possible surtout
que nantes comme aide énorme maladresse
à l'image de son arrière droit à iasi le
ballon est récupéré par le capitaine
dominique bathenay trouve rocheteau une
talonnade henri michel est battu
boubacar deux à zéro c'est sur le même
score que nantes avait emporté samedi
dernier au stade marcel saupin
c'est à dire qu'à la 17e minute de cette
partie les deux équipes se retrouvent à
égalité
mais la machine nantaise est déréglé le
paris saint-germain en profitent comme
rocheteau qui prend régulièrement le
dessus sur son adversaire direct le
stoppeur numéro 4 et 6 patrice rio toko
le ballon le poteau oui mais ce ballon
on va toucher les fils et dégâts des
buts de bertrand demanes 3 à 0
incroyable nantes qui n'a jamais perdu
avec plus d'un but d'écart cette saison
en championnat bien alors que ces trois
but en seulement 26 minutes
attention à cette action nantaise
rampillon sur son bon pied le gauche 3 à
à égalité au total des deux matches mais
vous connaissez le règlement en cas
d'égalité l'équipe ayant marqué le plus
grand nombre de but à l'extérieur est
qualifiée c'est à dire qu'à cet instant
de la partie non est qualifié et on
approche de la mi temps monsieur qu'on
rate larbitre ne va pas tarder à siffler
lorsque trop sert aux armes son pied
gauche 3 à 2 incroyable nantes est
revenu trois buses à deux ça se présente
maintenant très très mal pour le paris
saint-germain
puisque ce score de 3 à 2 sur le score à
la mi temps les parisiens attaquent tout
de même avec dahleb nous sommes à la 57e
minute de la partie
boubacar pour toko qui n'est pas
hors-jeu toko glisse valeur au château
il n'a plus qu'à pousser le ballon voilà
qui est fait 4 à 2 tout est encore
possible pour le psg
il hante et sont rarement en position
d'attaqué attention à celle ci tout de
même morin était mal placé les déborder
par loïc amisse et à guerbet qui avait
remplacé tour et marque encore pour nan
contre le cours du jeu 4 à 3 1 but qui
fait vraiment très mal surtout
moralement mais les parisiens continuent
on ne sait jamais dahleb pour rocheteau
perd le ballon
c'est bathenay qui le récupèrent nous
sommes à la 65e minute centre de battles
et but de taupo 5 à 3 à la 65e minute
en plus clair il reste 25 minutes aux
parisiens pour se qualifier
il suffit bien entendu de marquer un but
sans en concéder un seul
bien évidemment il reste 25 minutes
lorsque rocheteau s'échappe sur la
droite il reste huit minutes petite
faute d'henry michel monsieur corps
apathie siffler penalty non
plus que cinq minutes de jeu tous les
nantais sont aux abords de la surface de
réparation de bertrand demanes rocheteau
tout seul il tire alors qu'il pouvait
centrer sur dahleb bien mieux placé à un
mètre des buts seulement de bertrand
demanes qui était battu sur cette action
incroyable
nous étions pas loin de la qualification
pour paris qui attaquent toujours
seulement trois petites minutes de jeu
bathenay il ya deux parisiens à droite
trop chaud les a vus taleb le gardien
repousse cette fois il ya but c'est la
qualification non bertrand de balle
sauve une nouvelle fois bathenay sur la
gauche de votre écran accompli accompli
que maintenant nantes est qualifié et
oui 5 à 3 le paris saint germain qui m'a
été la qualification est éliminé mais
vraiment un match extraordinaire n'ayons
pas peur des mots
un match qui nous rappelle un petit peu
la coupe d'europe autant de
saint-etienne en 75 76